salut à tous cette vidéo est sponsorisée
parpn ce mois-ci une offre
exceptionnelle car du 28
[Applaudissements]
novembre spiderider
net
quo queéc pas en fait et en plus du 28
novembre au 9 janvier inclus chaque
utilisateur souscrivant n'importe quel
abonnement nordvpn de 2 ans recevra une
carte cadeau Amazon.fr d'une valeur
croissante en fonction de l'abonnement
choisi acheter n'importe quel équipement
électronique livre produit numérique
appareil électroménager 30 jours après
avoir démarré votre abonnement à D VPN
et bien d'autres choses encore je peux
acheter un VPN avec euh et bien alors
étonnemment oui j'ai regardé sur Amazon
et on peut acheter un VPN avec
effectivement mais alors si j'achète un
VPN et que j'ai une carte cadeau et
qu'avec la Carte Cadeau j'achète un
autre VPN et que j'ai une autre carte
cadeau et que j'achète un autre voulez
quoi vous voulez quoi je sais pas en
fait bénéficier de 4 mois offerts et
recevez jusqu'à 30 € en carte cadeau
Amazon sur tout abonnement de 2 ans à
nvpn en passant par le lien en
description offre valable jusqu'au 9
janvier 2024 limité à la France et à la
Belgique oh non tu m'as bloqué mon
rondpoint et je passe un projet loi avec
le 493 cette réforme est nécessaire
encore mais ça fait TR fois qui hexagone
le jeu de société où vous dirigez une
France en proie aux émeutes et aux
violences policières j'envoie les
CRS nous sommes en guerre oh non j'ai
pas ma 8e dose avec du savon ouais
exagone le jeu de société où vous
dirigez la France ou du moins où vous
essayez un jeu
[Musique]
annulé
et une nouvelle mode secoue les réseaux
sociaux aujourd'hui avec une trend qui
monte de plus en plus c'est le hashtag
dévisse le pneu d'une voiture challenge
une mode qui consiste à se balader dans
la rue et dévisser les pneus d'une
voiture au hasard Karen et bien cher
Pierre-Henry il va bien falloir que je
vérifie ma voiture en la sortant du
parking sans aucun lien l'ex youtubeur
Joueur du Grenier est mort aujourd'hui
dans un accident de voiture ses pneus ce
serait détaché sur l'autoroute et oui il
faut bien entretenir sa voiture sinon
voilà ce qui arrive dans un instant la
météo c'est bon on a un
[Musique]
signal monsieur ça fonctionne bien allez
au boulot appelez-moi les meilleurs
experts cette machine vaut des millions
prenez-en
soin
charger la
[Musique]
grille trop
chargé trop simpliste
c'est pas mal ça ça coûte combien 45 €
ou là non maiste
rien quand j'appuie sur Alt ça me
dit vous n'avez pas les privilèges
d'administration il doit y avoir un
système cela fait des années que les
réseaux sociaux détruisent le cerveau de
nos enfants que des influenceurs verreux
exploitent notre jeunesse Internet est
devenu une terre sans fois ni lois je
sais bien moi-même j'en ai fait les
frais j'ai suivi une formation de
youtubeur en ligne j'ai créé ma chaîne
d'ouverture de cartes Pokémon d'ailleurs
j'ai fait une vidéo aveci c'est quand
même pas de de la merde quoi enfin bon
c'est pas la question voilà la solution
laissez-moi vous
présenter
m-
372_63 modèle T8 version
2 quoi c'est un nom de
robot ah merde la prise attendez vous
avez vraiment oublié de lui [ __ ] une
[Musique]
batterie allez par en patrouille
accompli ta mission tu dois les éduquer
les sensibiliser sur les dangers des
réseaux sociaux et
d'Internet tu dois les
protéger 103 central on nous signale un
regroupement de tiktokers sur la 3è
Avenue
[Musique]
hey salut m pe j'espère que vous allez
bien en tout cas moi ça va super
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour le JAV
la javelle challenge en tout cas
j' pasle
[Musique]
oui j'ai openheimer prends possession de
moi ah mais [ __ ] mais ça fait mal tu
es un fou ah mais c'est super
dangereux
soyez SAG écoutez vos
parents ce 2 sur la 48 37 et on va dire
je pose le téléphone ici bonjour mes
petits clous franchement j'ai découvert
un shampoing trop bien je l'utilise le
matin le midi le soir à chaque repas et
franchement j'ai la tête toute
pro
[Musique]
1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça remonte à loin mais dans les années
80 il y a eu une petite bulle de films
sortis au cinéma qui étit ultra violent
mais qui pourtant ont eu droit à leur
lot de produits dérivés pour les enfants
typiquement Terminator à sa sortie en 84
était classé r c'est-à-dire interdit au
moins de 16 ans et pourtant dans les
magasins on pouvait trouver des tas de
jouets sur Terminator ou même des jeux
vidéos ce qui est bizarre hein parce que
c'est censé du coup être des jouets ou
des jeux faits pour les enfants mais sur
un film qui ne sont pas censés avoir vu
et une autre licence bien connue qui a
eu droit au même phénomène c'est Robocop
film culte de Paul veroven sorti en 87
qui raconte les aventures de Murphy
ancien flic assassiné puis ramené à la
vie sous les traits de Robocop un cborg
policier le film est ultra viiolent il y
a du sang à gogo des meurtres des
tentatives de viol des gens qui fondent
dans de l'acide et qui se font éc éasé
par des bagnoles et pourtant à l'époque
et ben tiens allez prends ton jouet
Robocop ton jeu vidéo ton dessin animé
ton cartable ta lunch BO et j'espère que
tu vas quand même l'apprécier alors que
tu ne l'as pas vu parce que tu ne l'as
pas vu n'est-ce pas ça serait
irresponsable côté jeux vidéo le premier
jeu Robocop sur console sortira en 1988
sur NES soit 1 an après le film ZDX
spectrum àari St et évidemment c'est du
run and gun classique qui ressemble à la
plupart des jeux tirés de film de cette
époque on y joue un Robocop squelettique
qui ne peut pas sauter il y a pas de
plateforme dans le jeu on utilise des
escaliers pour pas passer de niveau à
l'autre et je vais pas me plaindre de ça
hein ne pas avoir de plateforme de merde
à gérer honnêtement ça me va très bien
et rien qu'en voyant quelques images et
bien vous comprenez instantanément quel
genre de jeu ça va
[Musique]
être et aussi que vous allez très vite
détester la musique le je lui-même bon
c'est pas horrible ou alors il faudrait
dire que tous les jeux de l'époque sont
horribles hein est-ce que je peux dire
ça non he mais par contre ce jeu est un
très bel exemple de ce que j'appelle le
cercle de l'emmerdement sur les vieux
jeux et je vais vous faire un schéma
c'est un truc qu'on retrouve dans plein
de vieux jeux de la nesse hein ou de
jeux de l'époque les ennemis arrivent en
permanence sur vous tout le temps il y
en a pile un peu trop pour que vous
arriviez à tout gérer bonus en plus d'un
Robocop parce que vous ne pouvez pas
sauter donc impossible d'esquiver les
balles et du coup vous prenez des dégâts
en permanence jusqu'à en crever donc du
coup pour pas mourir ben vous voulez
jouer prudemment mais vous ne pouvez pas
jouer prudemment parce que cette barre
et cette lettre T en bas là c'est un
timer et vous n'avez déjà presque pas
assez de temps pour finir les niveaux
donc pour finir le niveau à temps ben
vous devez foncer mais vous ne pouvez
pas non plus parce que si vous foncez
vous prenez trop de dégâts et vous
n'avez pas assez de points de vie et du
coup ben retour à la case 1 le cercle de
l'emmerdement et votre plaisir à vous et
bien il est là et comme vous pouvez le
constater et bien les deux ne se
touchent
pas tout ça est très sérieux les
amis mais bon heureusement lesus sont
infinis hein comme ça on peut infiniment
s'emmerder Robocop ne se décourage
jamais ouais
ben Robocop je sais pas mais moi oui le
deuxième jeu Robocop est sorti en 88 un
jeu dans le même style la différence
étant qu'ici on peut enfin sauter et
même glisser et là je lui dis comme par
hasard c'est toujours les glisser dans
le jeu parce que vraiment votre
personnage a une inertie tellement
violente qu'on dirait qu'il a deux
caisses de savon sous les pieds e s
connais j'ai lâché le bouton pour courir
ici non mais merde bon alors pour parler
du jeu sinon visuellement ça ressemble
au premier on va alterner entre deux
types de niveau pendant tout le jeu les
usines pourries et les villes pourries
comme dans le film avec cette célèbre
ville de D3 très connu pour ces trois
lunes niveau gameplay il y a quand même
une nouveauté puisque vous avez un
certain nombre d'arrestations de
méchants à faire et de drogue à
récupérer dans chaque niveau j'ai
l'impression que c'est de la
marijuana avec cet écran de fin
qui dure une
éternité à chaque
fois
allez
allez et le petit bisou supplémentaire
c'est que si vous n'arrêtez pas assez de
méchants ou que vous ne récupérez pas
assez de drogue dans les niveaux et bien
vous devrez refaire le niveau en entier
avec au passage la punition de devoir
refaire un genre de stage de rattrapage
des points du permis dans un stand de
tir où il faudra tuer les ennemis et
tuer la drogue en évitant de tuer les
femmes et alors ce qui est vraiment très
con par contre c'est que quand tu
échoues au stage de rattrapage c'est pas
un game over ah tu peux tout fluguer et
tout rater ça ne change absolument rien
tu reprends juste le niveau comme si
rien ne s'était passé très bien je vois
que vous avez échoué à tout V test
et bien écoutez votre mission peut
reprendre comme prévu et pour votre
défense cette femme a vraiment l'airéque
mais le vrai petit bonbon de ce jeu
c'est clairement son level design
parfois vous allez finir les niveaux et
le jeu vous dira que vous n'avez pas
ramassé assez de drogue ou arrêter assez
de criminels et que donc et bien il faut
refaire le niveau donc ben pas le choix
du coup vous le refaites en prenant bien
garde ce coup-ci de bien ramasser toute
la drogue et d'arrêter tous les
criminels que vous voyez mais non
toujours pas encore et encore et vous
avez beau refaire toujours pas assez de
pourcentage pour passer au niveau
suivant ah oui alors personnellement
j'adore refaire les même niveau en
boucle comme ça pendant des heures
j'adore ça mais vous savez ce que j'aime
encore plus le meurtre et bien la
solution les amis c'est que les niveaux
sont trufés de passage caché impossible
à deviner la [ __ ] de ta grosse fleur
c'est c'est un espace entre deux pièges
rien dit que E c'est trop demandé de
[ __ ] une putaine flèche blanche sur le
mur et chaque niveau à droit à sa crotte
de nez là je dois faire quoi maintenant
j'ai de nouveau tout ramassé j'ai de
nouveau pas assez de points pour passer
au niveau suivant je je je vais où tu
veux que je fasse quoi le jeu là dis-moi
ce que tu veux tu veux que je me roule
la manette sur la gueule
[Musique]
regarde
alors bien sûr j'ai pas évoqué la
difficulté on est sur un bon gros
classique de la torture je dirais niveau
niveau CIA en vrai ça fait 15 ans qu'on
fait ça presque et je suis quand même
étonné de la créativité par moment et
pourtant je pensais avoir tout vu on a
des plateformes piégées des grapins qui
vont t'attraper et te jeter dans le vide
m plus loin des missiles qui t'arrivent
dans le cul et te font traverser toute
la carte pour te tuer au bout des trucs
sur lesquels tu vas marcher et qui
inversent les contrôles ah c'est un
cauchemar je dois tirer sur des ennemis
éviter des trucs qui me one shot sauter
sur des plateformes et le tout avec les
contrôles inversés
stop
stop c'est pour des enfants ils savent
même pas boutonner leur chemises stop et
bien sûr j'évoque même pas la diarhée
visuelle que c'est même selon des
standards d' a 40 ans le jeu est un pou
il y a des gros giryophares des dents
qui sortent du sol des chaînes violettes
qui pendent du Pla à fond des murs en
papier bullle bref on est arrivé
jusqu'au dernier boss mais impossible de
le battre ah même avec un émulateur
impossible et c'est pas faute d'avoir
essayé ah il te renvoie les balles il te
balance des trucs par-dessus des trucs
pardessous des fois les deux en même
temps tout en te fonçant dessus derrière
non mais
oh ça va merde alors bon je sais que les
puristes du retro gaming ils vont être
genre
oh tu pouvais complètement esquiv quoi
je veux dire suffit de connaître le
pattern mais pour moi et 90 % des gens
je pense que c'est impossible en fait je
suis en train de voir sur le net là il y
a des gens qui arrivent à battre le boss
il y a une strate en fait c'est super
simple j'ai dit
impossible Robocop 3 sera dans la même
lignée le jeu a cependant au moins une
idée de gameplay originale dans chaque
niveau vous subirez des dégâts qui
endommageront différentes parties de
votre corps jambes bras corps et tête et
en fonction de l'endroit où vous subirez
les dégâts et bien robocope va rater
certaines actions qui seront
matérialisés par des messages gris
indiquant les dysfonctionnements de
votre armure si votre corps est en
endommager parfois et bien vous allez
appuyer sur le bouton de saut mais votre
personnage ne sautera pas si c'est les
jambes le jeu va de temps en temps vous
bloquer purement et simplement si c'est
les bras il vous empêchera de tirer et
enfin si c'est la tête allumette et si
c'est la tête et bien les contrôles vont
parfois s'inverser de manière
alléatoire je vais citer Yann Malcom
vous étiez tellement préoccupé par ce
que vous pouviez faire que vous ne vous
êtes pas demandé si vous en aviez le
droit le jeu est archi dur de base
est-ce que c'était vraiment n mais
[ __ ] comment ça le lex malfonction me
bloque pendant un saut comme si j'avais
Orter un mur ça marche comment ta merde
mes jambes sont tellement pétées
qu'elles ont annulé le principe physique
de l'inersy et [ __ ] leur truc éta
incompréhensible les messages défil à
toute vitesse et les TR qu4s disent des
choses contradictoires efficacité
augmenté malfonction des jambes protéger
l'innocent mal fonction du corps vous
n'avez plus d'essence le pneu est
dégonflé il fait 30 25°g tout va très
bien le moteur va exploser dans 3
secondes efficacité maximale vous venez
de renverser un
enfant alors bon entre chaque niveau
vous pourrez quand même réparer roboccop
certes mais les trucs de réparation sont
archi rares c'est même marqué dans le
livre à quel point c'est rare et c'est
au rythme de 10 % par réparation alors
que je finis chaque niveau complètement
en ruine mais bon sur l'écran titre du
jeu il y a une gamine avec un fling et
ça c'est cool paradoxalement le meilleur
jeu Robocop ça sera Robocop versus
Terminator sur SuperNes la difficulté
est enfin abordable c'est même un petit
peu l limite d'après la vitesse des
balles des ennemis je dirais qu'on est
sur des bulles de savon niveau calibre
mais bref on va pas se plaindre le jeu
est très très beau on s'amuse et surtout
on se sent enfin puissant comme Robocop
contrairement à tous les jeux que j'ai
mentionné
avant c'était effectivement une très
jolie couille mon cher Pierre-Henri sans
transition maintenant on vient de
l'apprendre les chiffres sont tombés de
la part du ministère les comportements
problématiques sur internet ont diminué
de 4 %. on y voit déjà le résultat des
actions du
m-372 robe- du bas 63 modèle T8 version
2 que le public surnomme déjà
affectueusement robe merci Karen etant
que nous sommes là dedans un autre
chiffre les crimes violents ont augmenté
de 378 % gros chiffre et voilà l'affaire
est dans le
sac avec tout ça les gens vont commencer
à se plaindre de la manière violente
dont ce robot clown gère la situation
ils vont se tourner vers des solutions
moins extrêmes plus efficaces et surtout
surtout dans leur budget et vous voyez
c'est là que
[Musique]
j'interviens je vous présente safe space
firewall antivirus antimalware mais
surtout blocage du pub des ails
fruduleux du dropshipping de tous les
gens qui veulent vous vendre quelque
chose et d'une manière générale qui vous
protège de tout ce qui est stupide de
toute discussion politique de tout ce
qui peut vous affecter négativement de
quelque manière que ce soit sur
n'importe quel réseau social alors
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez euh vous
vous le prenez ou pas le chirachier au
saumon du coup tenez essayez par
vous-même mais je comprends pas il y a
rien qui s'affiche là exactement et avec
sa face vous êtes complètement protégé
et grâce à ça je vais me faire des
dizaines d'euros que du des centaines
d'euros maintenant que mon plan est en
place j'ai bien peur de ne plus avoir
besoin de
vous mais du coup vous voulez pas votre
chirachi 57 12 et le numéro
complémentaire
on a une requête spéciale ça vient
directement des gros bonnets rz-vous au
13 carrefour de l'embuscade à côté du
parc du complot c'est dans le quartier
du piège non c'est dans l'avenue du
trackenard
terminé évidemment les jeux n'allaient
pas rester que sur les vieilles consoles
c'est l'avantage des licences comme
Terminator Robocop c'est un temporel
après une absence étonnante sur
Playstation 1 il faudra donc attendre la
PlayStation 2 pour voir Robocop revenir
avec un jeu développé
[Musique]
par attends mais tu es sûr de ton coup
là parce que sur Wikipédia il y a marqué
que c'est développé par Titus pas par
oui pardon c'est un réflexe conditionné
alors pour rappel Titus on les a déjà
croisés dans un JDG c'est eux qui ont
développé Superman
64 pardon le jeu vous met donc dans la
peau de Robocop qui va devoir affronter
des criminels de la terrible ville de
D3 alors
euh non mais attendez vous êtes rentré
dedans normalement n'est-ce pas alors
expliquez-moi pourquoi vous pouvez pas
en ressortir
correctement et après un journal télé
qui se veut une parodie des journaux de
Robocop qui ressemble en fait plus à un
vieux SkyBlock des années 2000 et
je ne sais pas pourquoi mais tous les
humains ressemblent à Monsieur Patate le
jeu vous lance sur un briefing de
mission à
effectuer ok mais je vous ai déjà dit de
me [ __ ] la paix quand je suis en train
de chier le jeu est donc un FPS dans
lequel on va devoir accomplir plusieurs
objectifs qui dans tous les cas vont
impliquer de bousiller des criminels par
centaines allez
oh allez oh oh [ __ ] de oh c'est mais
merde mais allez vise le vise ah et oh
je rappellerai jamais assez à quel point
je déteste jouer un FPS avec une manette
mais cela dit heureusement ils ont mis
un système de visée automatique comme
dans le film une fois enclenché votre
personnage va cibler en rouge les
ennemis et tirer dessus de manière
automatique sauf que pour verrouiller
les ennemis et les viser automatiquement
il faut d'abord les viser manuellement
et ensuite appuyer sur rond pour lo ok
mais alors attendez une seconde si
jamais je réussis à viser les ennemis
manuellement une fois que j'ai réussi à
les viser manuellement à quoi ça me sert
d'appuyer sur le bouton pour les viser
automatiquement je monsieur votre idée
de merde ah merci
ah pourtant c'est même pas le plus gros
problème de ce système parce que bon une
fois est demi verrouillé Robocop se met
à tirer dessus jusqu'à sa mort ok sauf
que votre personnage se met à tirer sur
le centre des ennemis c'est le centre
des modèles des ennemis des modèles 3D
ça a été programmé comme ça pour des
questions de simplicité je suppose bref
centre des personnages qui se situe
sur donc vous voilà en train de vous
balader dans les rues de dtro en tirant
sur les [ __ ] de tous les criminels ce
qui au début est certes rigolo jusqu'au
moment où vous réalisez avec horreur que
si un ennemi est derrière un petit mur
ou une caisse et bien ça donne
ça montre-moi ta [ __ ] [ __ ] bon alors
après vous avez bien un système de viser
infrarouge pour vous aider à mieux viser
les ennemis
mais attendez je vais utiliser ma vision
tactique pour mieux viser de
loin
[Musique]
ah tiens un niveau dans les égouts
génial sur PS2 c'est vraiment exactement
ce que je voulais faire un [ __ ] de
niveau dans les égouts dans un je Rob oh
[ __ ] mal la taille du rat oh je vous
jure c'est vraiment sérieux là vous
allez vraiment faire tuer des rats dans
des égouts c'est le niveau 1 c'est le
niveau 1 vous avez déjà abandonné ah oui
alors d'ailleurs le jeu essaie de nous
placer un petit peu dans l'ambiance des
film avec des punch lin bien placé mais
je je rappelle qu'un policier est pas
censé prendre son kiif comme ça quand
même vous savez Murphy dans la police on
pense par que vous mais il faudra éviter
de le dire en public parce que là vous
allez nous griller attention P alors
après les ennemis ne sont pas en reste à
niveau
dialogue c'est qui qui faisait le
doublage bug Bunny d'ailleurs c'est quoi
le problème des doublages dans ce jeu ok
tu peux me faire le son d'un mec qui
meurt
maintenant et bien en fait j'ai pu
enregistrer ça lorsque je suis tombé des
escaniers mais ça va mieux j'ai pu aller
récupérer mon costume de momie pour
Halloween parce que oui effectivement
votre objectif ne sera pas que de tuer
des criminels il faudra aussi les
arrêter alors certains se rendront
directement en vous voyant dans un un
manque de courage absolu qui j'avoue me
fait beaucoup
rire mec tire pas tire pas je me
rends
quoi j'ai dit je me
rends et d'autres auront besoin de
quelques balles dans les couilles pour
se remettre dans le droit chemin euh
comme quoi
hein bref outre devoir tuer et capturer
des criminels jeu vous demandera aussi
souvent comme objectif de libérer des
civils qui sont dispersés un petit peu
partout dans chaque niveau et qu'il va
falloir chercher heureusement le jeu
t'aide un peu à accomplir tes objectifs
avec le vieux policier là qui te
prévient quand un age est pas trop
loin le problème c'est qu' t'aide un peu
trop souvent quand même
oui oui je sais je
sais oui je le
sais oui je le sais je cherche comment
acc id justement oh mon dieu mais mais
tais-toi ta
gueule il a des civil dans votre secteur
il a des civil dans votre secteur
secteur il a des cives dans votre roboc
vous devez les libérer la ferme
pitié il a des C dans votre secteur
pourquoi vous répondez
pas heureusement qu'on est là quand même
parce que vu il a du jeu les civils ils
allaient pas se sauver tout seul
merci Robocop j'ai cru qu'on allait
mourir de faim et de soif
ici contrairement à il a des adnemie qui
elle est fantastique et qui d'après la
couverture de la boîte Xbox est
adaptative et s'ajuste à la situation
alors attend comment je tourne ce
merdier mais non c'est pas par là que je
mais non je veux essayer de faire ah
mais comment cette
[Musique]
merde alors après à sa décharge c'est un
peu ce qui se passera je pense si un mec
t'attaquer avec un tractopel en
vrai je pense c'est pas du tout pratique
ah non vraiment les ennemis sont
complètement aveugles ils se bloquent
régulièrement contre les murs et dès
qu'ils utilisent des grenades tu peux
juste attendre gentiment sans rien faire
parce que tu peux être sûr qu'ils vont
finir par se tuer tout seul le pire
étant je pense les boss notamment
celui-là je je sais pas ce que c'est
c'est il se contente de tourner sur
lui-même sans jamais m'attaquer pas même
une seule fois il fait rien il m'a juste
chié une clé à molette dans la panique
là bref le jeu possède SEP niveau en
tout qui nous permet de visiter cette
vision d'un futur dystopique où les
grosses portes de bateau rouillé sont
fermé électroniquement
la fameuse suspension d'incrédulité et
bon alors au passage je glisse un petit
mot vite fait sur les graphismes c'est
pas méga beau mais c'est pas moche non
plus on va dire que c'est dans les
standards un petit peu bas de la
PlayStation 2 en revanche par contre on
sent que les développeurs ils ont
renversé sur la table tous les modèles
3D qu'ils avaient sans trop réfléchir à
comment les assembler ah sympa les
bureaux bon alors par contre quand il
pleut c'est vrai que ça doit pas être
ouf et oh pas mal ces chiottes ouvertes
là où tout le monde peut te regarder
chier oh c'est convivial et ah là il y a
du mieux par contre dans ce niveau il y
a des portes dans les chiottes mais
toujours un problème de conception
niveau placement
bon alors évidemment le jeu n'allait pas
suivre le film faut pas déconner on a
des niveaux dans des catacombes des
trains de Lamine des grottes de cristaux
des cathédrales des meufs robots sexies
qui tirent des éclairs magiques ou des
kamameamea
alors bon je veux bien que mes souvenirs
du film remontent à loin mais il y avait
pas de cathédrale et oui au fait
d'ailleurs au passage quand tu meurs
dans les niveaux tu te fais
[Applaudissements]
huer bah super bah merci les gars
imagine tu es un policier mort qu'on
ramène à la vie pour le faire travailler
plus longtemps on t'envoie seul
affronter 300 mecs tu remeurs en
opération une seconde fois et à ton
enterement tu as tes potes qui sont
genre j'ai même pas parlé des scènes
cinématiques je sais même pas comment
vous parle des scènes
[Musique]
cinématiques oh non
Robocop qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé là on est devenu un film
indien
[Musique]
subitement bref pour comprendre ce qui
s'est passé avec ce jeu on peut
peut-êtreou ouver un début de réponse
dans les making of
ouais moi aussi j'aurais enquêté sur eux
dans ces bonus disponible uniquement sur
la version collector des Xbox on peut y
voir par exemple des brainstorming
créatif mal cadré je j'ai pas zoomé dans
l'image là c'était vraiment cadré comme
ça dans le tu filmes quoi la réunion ou
l'autoroute 1 vers lîle et bref autant
dire que ces réunions avaient l'air de
puer le
fun bref le jeu donc nous montre les
différents coup pardon les différents
collaborateurs on peut voir des
designers des programmeurs des concepts
artistes on peut voir la création des
personnages du jeu magnifiquein et ben
je je crois que c'est elle là dans le
jeu
ouais et clairement on peut voir aussi
qu'on travaille dans une ambiance saine
et détendue comme La Teste c'est vieuxat
cing à palav mais regardons plutô la
conclusion qui parle
d'ême le studious fera suite à ce je
liquidation judiciire l'année suivante
roboc sera le dernier
je oupsi et d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote
Titus était actionnaire majoritaire de
interplay éditeur qui possédait
notamment les studios black e un
développeur très connu dans les années
90 puisqu'il possédait des licences
comme ice windell fallous ou balders
gate donc en crevant Titus c'est pas
contentter de crever avec Robocop et
Superman 64 ils ont aussi amené dans la
tombe un paquet de bon jeu avec eux
après cet échec retentissant Robocop va
complètement disparaître du jeu vidéo en
même temps la licence est assez vieille
jusqu'à ben étonnamment le hasard du
calendrier C année puisqueun nouveau jeu
Robocop doit être sorti à peu près au
moment où vous regardez cette
vidéo vous êtes en état d'arrestation
toute résistance
entraînera votre mort
ah
pardon préparez-vous il arrive apportez
les
[Musique]
flagues
bon c'est
ouvert qui est le propriétaire de la
Renault Méane rouge malgarer
dehors vous avez 10 secondes
pour attendez c'est ici le 13 carrefour
de
l'embuscade tu es tombé dans le piège le
poulet quel
[Musique]
piège ah mais patron je vous l'avais dit
que ça marchera jamais bon tant pis on
passe au plan B monsieur à propos des
armes qu'on nous a livré je veux pas le
savoir
[Musique]
ah c'est n'importe quoi on va jamais
réussir à le tuer
avec
[Musique]
dis-moi pour qui tu travailles
crapu faire huiler poulet je te dirai
rien ok ok je vais tout dire d'accord n
en 1974 d'une mère boulangère et d'un
père trafiquant de
drogue d'accord d'accord je va la la son
nom
[Musique]
c'est
bien je vois qu'il faut tout faire par
[Musique]
somême ça aurait été bien plus pratique
si vous étiez mort bien gentiment vous
étiez censé crever après avoir foutu le
bordel ça vous rappelle quelque
chose les nouvelles mode secou les
réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui avec une
trend hash le P d'une voiture challenge
c'est moi qui lancé ses trend et
maintenant vous avez foutu en l'air mon
plan laissez-moi vous présenter mon plan
b b
[Musique]
comme
pas mal je vois vous avez anticipé la
taille des portes mais ce n'est que le
plan B nous allons passer tout de suite
au plan C en avant monsieur
[Musique]
shinigami qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
pauvre robot minable on t'a implanté une
directive secrète qui t'empêche de t'en
prendre à tes
[Musique]
créateursenire pas mon créateur mon
créateur est celui qui a assembl les
circuits de ma carte mère je suis s que
génie est en de mettre point robot
encore plus puissant que moi pour lutter
contre les cules de votre
espèce
c'est
impossible effectivement Karen je ne
savais pas qu'un doigt de pied pouvait
être aussi sexy sans transition vient de
la prendre le président de méchant Corp
a été arrêté aujourd'hui
monsieur de son nom a été démis de ses
fonctions et sera remplacé dès lundi par
Monsieur shinigami son assistant qui n'a
pas souhaité faire de déclaration à la
presse et sur un tout autre autre sujet
une nouvelle trend vient d'apparaître
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est le hashtag
Factory shooting qui consiste à lancer
des fusillades dans les usines Rob le
policio des réseaux sociaux aurait
déclaré ah [ __ ] de monde de merde j'en
peux plus il faudrait tout cramer et
tout cramer c'est justement la traine du
[Musique]
jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]